so the new Black Panther film is out and
it's awesome and a few people have
requested that I make a black panther
training video in the same vein as my
Batman training video my arrow training
video at first I was a little bit
reluctant because Black Panthers
actually got superpowers he's connected
to his ancestors and he can jump super
high and he's super strong he's covered
in vibranium I wanted to make these
videos more kind of grounded and
potentially achievable and then I
realized there is a lot I can cover here
Black Panthers a guy who's got super
agility can jump super high it's got
heightened senses and there are ways we
can train to improve all these things so
stay tuned what stress this video and
will cover how to move like a cat how to
always land on your feet and how to leap
through the trees and run with speed and
grace what I'm going to go into a lot of
detail in this video and how to jump
higher become more agile and flexible
and more powerful I am gonna go into a
bit more depth on certain points in the
blog post which I'll link to in the
description down below ok so first of
all I should mention that Black Panther
is a bit like Batman in that he's not
just all about the muscle and the speed
he's also a genius he's incredibly well
educated with multiple degrees and he
knows apparently pretty much all the
martial arts I've talked in the past
about how you can learn more fit more
learning into your schedule and I've
talked about accelerated learning
techniques and brain plasticity so won't
go over that again I'll leave links in
the description down below check out my
videos on Sherlock Holmes on Batman and
on learning to code with accelerated
learning one thing I didn't want to
touch on though is the concept of
learning all the martial arts which I
discussed in the Batman video instead
ultimately it's not feasible
there's thousands of different
variations of different styles of
martial art and it's gonna take you a
minimum of ten years to really get the
basics you know to even slightly master
a martial art to reach black belt status
let alone to become you know a true
master a Grand Master who you know
completely understands every facet of
the style so a few people commented down
below and said that
what you could do instead is to learn
just the basic styles of martial arts
you know your karate your kung-fu your
judo and then to add on top of that just
a few techniques from different styles
and that would be pretty much the same
thing and I've got a few issues with
that first of all there's a lot more
difference between different styles of
martial art then you might think I need
capoeira Tai Chi and karate they're all
completely different I mean capoeira is
all about rhythm and swinging your legs
around and it looks like a dance and Tai
Chi's about slow movements and
concentration and karate is essentially
a combat sport so there's very little
overlap even between what a roué karate
in Shotokan there's a lot of different
Shotokan it's all about hard strikes
while the ROO incorporates some softer
aspects of martial arts so things like
blocks and moving with the opponent's
energy etc and then you've got things
like Krav Maga you've got things like
jiu-jitsu like Aikido you've got weapon
martial arts you've got things like pug
wow these are all so different there's
very little similarity between them and
the other issue I take is that one
you've learned a martial art really well
the whole point is that you'll rote to
learning movement these are movement
patterns and by repeating the same punch
the same kick over and over and over
again what you're doing is you're
cementing those new pathways in your
nervous system in your brains so the
more you've beaten movement the more
that the network's in your brain
corresponding to that movement become
myelinated and this means that those
neural connections are better insulated
and it's more easy for you to access
them and to repeat them over and over so
the whole point is that you'll report
repeating the same punch the same kick
as Bruce Lee says it's better to
practice one kick a thousand times than
a thousand kicks once because you're
going to become better at performing
that movement quickly and effectively
and at executing it when you need it as
a reflex and black panthan of course is
all about reflexes now when I tried kung
fu recently I had to go at Wing Chun I
came in and they started showing me how
to block and things and it's all about
moving with the opponent's energy a
little similar type to Tai Chi and they
they throw a punch to me said what's
your instinct and I did an inner block
karate in a block and so I had to
unlearn that the d-train that in order
to become better at kung-fu this is
called the interference principle it's
often applied to athletics and sports
because as it become better one it often
least detriment in another modality and
so the same thing happens in martial
arts if you become really good at karate
it might actually impede your ability to
block using a kung-fu technique so
realistically I don't think it's
feasible or even a particularly good
strategy to try and master every single
martial art but what I would say is that
what you can do is to incorporate lots
of different martial arts into a new
style that is your style and that works
for you and that's how a lot of martial
art styles like Krav Maga are born and
like Jeet Kune Do famously so absorb
what is useful and reject the rest to
repeat the same punch in the same kick
but then bring in other useful
strategies from elsewhere and devised
your own style and that's what a lot of
true masters end up doing is taking
different component from different
martial arts and creating their own
style so if I were really to charla
trying to become the black panther
rather than trying to learn every single
martial art I'd find a kind of base
martial art that agreed with my body
type practice practice practice and then
learn as many techniques from elsewhere
as possible I think that's the most
realistic equivalent to learning every
martial art of course mixed martial arts
is a good way to get into this or you
can just try dabbling in a few different
ones
but the thrust of this video I want to
be about improving your jumping height
your balance your prep prior section so
how do we train in order to improve
those things
well proprioceptive is your ability to
sense your body in space this is what
gives you a sense of balance along with
your inner ear and it's what allows you
to become more agile because if you know
where your body is then you're not going
to be clumsy and flailing around all
over the place
so proprioceptive is handled by
proprioceptors and the one we're going
to be looking at here is the muscle
spindle so a muscle spindle is found on
all your muscles and as your muscles
lengthen the muscle spindle lengthens
and this provides feedback to your brain
to tell you the length of your muscles
and therefore where they must be in
space so this is what allows you to
build that mental image of your own body
moving
through space muscle spinners are also
very important for something called
reflexive strength and this is what
helps us to balance and to not fall over
so what happens is when you start
falling forwards that means a muscle is
gonna suddenly lengthen without you
consciously having told it to and this
sends feedback to your brain and what it
wants to do is to contract the muscle
and shorten again to therefore writing
you so if you start falling then you'll
get feedback from your gluteus medius
and other supporting muscles telling you
to write in yourself they'll shorten
you'll stand straight back up so how can
you increase your muscle spindle
sensitivity well by stretching and being
mindful of your muscles so when we pay
attention when we're more mindful of
different senses this allows us to
improve our mind muscle connection and
therefore to heighten our ability to
sense them in future through
neuroplasticity so practice balancing
practice stretching and as you're doing
those things focus and feel your muscles
moving through space be aware of your
entire body and that way you'll be
listening to those muscle spindles and
increasing your proprioceptive of course
you know I'm all about said specific
adaptations to impose demands and that
means that if you want to improve at
something you need to do more of it so
if you want to improve it balance then
of course you need to balance more and
use balancing exercises so anything
where you're standing on one leg such as
a one-legged car phrase for instance or
anything where you're leaning back such
as a [ __ ] squat which can be a bit
tough on your knees but you know check
with your doctor it can also be used to
rehabilitate your knees so it's not
entirely bad you just need to be very
careful anything like that where you're
balancing or even hand balancing will
allow you to listen out to those muscle
spindles once at the same time building
strength in the small supportive muscles
that keep your body straight and in the
core which is very important hand
balancing is actually a fantastic way to
strengthen your core and to build those
supportive muscles and prevent yourself
from being easily knocked over hand
balancing being anything like a
handstand push-up or like a planche or
even just like crow pose which is a good
place to start and then build up any
kind of compound exercise at the same
time will also allow you to build these
supportive muscles I talked recently
about loaded carries and lifting a trap
bar and walking with it this is
fantastic from
stabilizing muscles especially in the
hips and again if you're more
consciously listening and watching you
in biomechanics as you do this then
you'll improve your ability to balance
and stay upright
another very useful form of training is
contralateral training so any movement
that trains your right arm and your left
leg or your left arm and your right leg
such as press ups where you're on one
hand and the opposite leg or such as
spider-man crawls or lizard crawls
anything like this because you're these
two sides of your body
neurologically linked your left arm your
right leg etc and this is why when we
walk we see our arms and move in the
opposite direction so by training this
you can improve your ability to
coordinate the two sides of your body to
use them as a single unit and again to
be a little less flailing a little more
accurate the thing with any kind of
training like balance training etc is
that it takes a lot of time out of our
gym and that's why I highly recommend
something like doing one-legged calf
raises or one-legged squats because
these are also training a legs so at the
same time is building strength in your
leg you're getting that added benefit of
some balance training and if you want to
engage your proprioceptors even more
during this then try closing your eyes
and ruling out your other senses so
you're focusing just on those muscle
spindles and using them along with your
inner ear to write yourself my video on
explosive training I talked about
explosive eccentrics and this means
anything where you're absorbing an
impact where you're catching yourself as
you fall away you're catching away for
example depth jumps where you jump off
of something high and then straight back
up into the air the best way to do this
is by jumping off of something 43 inches
off the ground don't go higher than that
until you can squat a lot and then
launching yourself straight back up in
the air spending no more than naught
point two seconds touching the ground
this will improve your your reflexive
strength it will improve your
flexibility but it also improves your
jump height your explosiveness and in
one study athletes were shown to
increase their jump height by 13% by
using this kind of protocol and of
course it's also improved ability to
land softly and stealthily which of
course is something that the Black
Panther would have to do quite a lot now
we're talking more about jump Heights
and explosiveness and of course that
should be a very important part of any
black panther training so add in those
explosive eccentrics what you can also
do is to just train with squats build up
the strength
your legs so that means you know
squatting heavy weights and leg press
etc if you want something more
interesting that you can focus on then
you need to train your flexor hallucis
longus and that is the muscle that
controls the movement of your big toe
and this is actually very responsible
for launching you in the air when you
jump and for helping you to land so how
do you train this one thing to do one of
the best exercises you can use is the
one-legged calf raise which we've
already talked about as a great way to
build your proprioceptors oh hold a
weight stand on one leg and then lower
and raise yourself remember if we're
training balance here we don't want have
an arm on the wall that's what we're
building up to so not only be building
your flexibility and your ability to
balance but it'll also be increasing
your jump height by building that
strength in that big toe this is the
best kind of exercise for GPT general
preparedness training because it has
multiple benefits it's allowing us to
build our balance our jump height and
our flexibility if you allow your leg to
move really nice and low when you're
doing those calf raises you can also use
calf jumps which I'm a big fan of calf
jumps mean that you're just jumping off
the ground explosively you don't bend
your legs you're just using your calves
to launch yourself in the air again this
will really train your ability to jump
like that and then that'll make sure
that's not on a weak link when you're
using your jumping technique another way
to train the muscles in your foot not
only for jump height but also for
balance is to use something like this
these are Vibram FiveFingers
be very careful because they can be hard
on your knees if you're not used to them
you need to work your way up start on
soft surfaces but these are basically
shoes that have got flexible toes and
what that allows you to do is to run to
climb to jump and to use the muscles in
your feet as you do which of course will
improve your billets to use them like
the Terra muhammara tribe who can run
huge distances without tiring out and
who never seem to fall over because
they've got so much strength and
stability in their ankles and in their
feet I've talked a little bit about
stretching in order to improve your
muscle spindle sensitivity and to allow
yourself to land more quietly but it
also has other benefits including
boosting your jump height that might
sound strange but that's because when a
muscle is tight and it's not at all
flexible it actually constantly exerts
force and resistance during your
movements so we have a muscle in the
front of our leg
in our Shin called the tibialis anterior
and this pulls our foot up all the time
so if that's tense if you haven't
stretched and loosened that up it's
constantly pulling your foot up so when
you try and jump and you're trying to
launch off the ground and put your foot
down it's fighting you so you need to
stretch and flex that muscle there and
then this will allow you to jump more
easily because you're removing that
resistance so just pulling your leg up
behind you and making sure to feel the
bend on your foot as well as your leg
will help you to train that and then you
should find not only can you jump higher
you can also even run faster running
fast is another of Black Panthers
abilities of course and all the training
we've discussed so far improving your
flexibility your foot muscles your
explosiveness that'll help you to run
faster at the same time you can also
find the link in the description down
below to another of my videos talking
about how to run fast like sonic and
you'll find many more tips on speed
drills etc that you can use there
finally the last thing you might want to
train in order to be more like Black
Panther is our senses because Black
Panther has super acute senses a bit
like wolverine or daredevil and that's
something else that allows them to fight
with amazing reflexes and to not get
snuck up on but even for a panther
cannot hear his victim
so how can we improve our senses well
once again this is something I've
already covered a little video I'm
training like daredevil I'll link to
that in the description down below but
just to go over the basics you want to
focus on using your senses in a cross
modal fashion so not focusing just on
your site or on your hearing but I'm
focusing on sound localization so that
means listening for things and then
working out where they came from in
space so a good exercise is to support
your mind for a moment listen to sounds
around you then try and guess where they
are and then find them and that's the
kind of training that they actually
teach to time-waster sound engineering
students they surrounded in a circle
they wear blindfold and have to identify
where sounds are coming from because
really that's what would be useful in a
fight isn't it knowing where someone
sneaking up on you or where an attack is
coming from so focus on not only
listening for sounds but working out
where they're coming from and using your
senses together if you're going to
practice walking through the house with
blindfold on trying not to break
anything including your own limbs then
something you can do is to focus not
only on your tactile senses but also on
sound also on temperature it's actually
we have many more than five senses and
by using them together you can get much
more information so if you're walking
through your house you might try and
feel the breeze coming from from a
window or you might try and feel a
change in the texture on the ground or a
creaky floorboard all these things can
give you more information about where
you are and it's using them together
like this that allow you to improve your
senses but a lot of its just mindfulness
it's focusing on those senses not just
ignoring them because there's so much
information that we ignore all the time
and when you become more mindful as
we've seen with the proprioceptive by
focusing on your limb length and things
like that you can increase your
awareness of that thing and thicken the
brain matter that helps you to be more
sensitive to that information we have
brain plasticity showing that you can
form more neurons corresponding to
different activities and abilities but
you also have visual plasticity meaning
that you can increase the number of
photoreceptors in your eye potentially
the studies that look at this are mainly
focusing on rehabilitation rather than
heightening your senses but in theory
it's possible to grow new receptors to
increase your visual acuity and
where you might do this is by focusing
more on your peripheral vision which we
don't pay much attention to we tend to
have a very narrow focused view and this
could actually birth new receptors to
increase our cutie in the periphery of
our vision and once again that's the
kind of sense that would be useful to a
black panther because it would allow you
to again see things creeping up and you
know where they're coming from and in
the sound localization and then you are
like you're like a cat I talked in a
previous video on how to use a technique
called splatter vision or wide-angle
vision or owl eyes in order to engage
your peripheral vision and a way to
practice this is to put your arms out by
your sides
to focus on your fingers like so and
then to keep your vision spread out like
that you lose a lot of the detail that
you get from focused vision but at the
same time you're taking in more
information and you're more aware of
your surroundings go and check out that
video if you want more information on
that but this researchers desk that
practicing this could actually increase
the number of photoreceptors in your
peripheral vision and thereby greatly
enhance your ability to see things
coming from either side today I hope
your fans video useful interesting guys
if you did then please leave a like
please share it around please comment
down below let me know what you think if
I missed anything if you can think of
any cool techniques that might be useful
to train more like Black Panther I've
got many more videos like this on the
way so stay tuned if you want more on
bodybuilding fitness martial arts
productivity transhumanism technology
nootropics if that all sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching I really mean
that
and bye for now